Abu Bakr, how you doing? I'm doing fine.
How are you? I'm pretty good. I'm pretty
good. Thank you for joining, man. Thank
you for joining. You're a Muslim, right?
Yes. Alhamdulillah.
Man, how are you a Muslim still with
this Islamic dilemma out here? The
dilemma is not actually a dilemma
because what I believe about the Quran
and in Islam, whenever you don't
understand anything in the Quran, the
problem is not the Quran. It's not the
prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam or Allah. The problem is our
level of knowledge. Yes. Well, the
Quran. Yeah. I'm willing to I'm willing
to put that to the test. I think that
you and I can reason together, read the
Quran for what it says, and see that the
Quran has an internal issue. Okay. All
right. So, I'm going to ask you this
question. What in the world is the NGO?
Yeah, according to Islam and the Quran
and the teachings in Islam is the
revelation from God Almighty given to
prophet Jesus peace be upon him. Okay.
Was it written down? But when the
revelation was revealed to him, no, it
was in oral form. Okay. And then
eventually maybe got written down later.
Yes, probably. But um I am not
definitely on that. So is a mayab for me
because the Quran and yeah the Quran is
saying something about descriptive
something uh was was written down. So is
kind of the formality that when a
prophet received the revelation the
scribes write it down. Yeah. For the
preservation because the go both written
and the oral tradition in preservation
of the the script. Gotcha. Yeah. Yeah.
The Quran actually does say that it was
written and in fact it says the in jail
the and the Torah they were both written
and that the Christians they have it in
Muhammad's time. Yeah. Written in your
scripture in your book. Yeah. So let me
ask you this then since we know that the
NGL according to the Quran was written
revelation of Jesus. It was oral at
first ended up getting written down. Who
do you think would have written it down
in jail? Probably uh the first followers
of Jesus Christ, the disciples will will
have the privilege of writing it down. I
like Yeah, I like that. Yeah, I agree.
Okay, I agree.
Um so you believe that the gospel is a
revelation that Jesus went around
preaching orally. It then got written
down most likely by his disciples,
right? his first followers who would
have had the privilege to write down
what the Lord spoke and um which is
good. So do you believe that I have the
gospel today? I believe you have uh the
teachings you have like more than uh
than the divine scripture because in
Islam we have the Quran which is pure
word of God and we have the Sunnah
outside of the Quran. So what what I see
because I read the Bible, what I see in
the Bible is like there is the word of
God and the commentary about how Jesus
taught that scripture to people. So it's
like a mixture of Yeah. It's like a
mixture. You're saying that the Bible
you're saying that what I have is I have
the gospel and I have the suna of Jesus
basically. Yes. Yes. according to my
understanding that's how because even
someone who is not a Christian can read
the Bible and doesn't have to look for
someone to interpret for him or her. So
because it like selfexplaining that
Jesus said this and there is additional
information to what he said. Got it. Got
it. Oh wow. So we have so we have the
angil in the Bible and we have basically
like the hadith of Jesus the suna of
Jesus in the Bible. So we have his
teachings and we also have like just you
know his life and how he practices
religion or the other things that he did
or places he went stuff like that. Cool.
That's how I see. Okay. Good. So then
when we have when we have since we have
what Jesus taught Jesus and the
obviously the Quran points to it as a
truth and and uh Christians should judge
by it and follow it. If they don't
they're wrongdoers. Everybody should
believe in all of Allah's scriptures. If
this is the case we see when we open up
the gospel we see what Jesus taught. He
taught that he was the son of God. He
taught that he came to give his life as
a ransom. Um and he taught that he's um
he died for our sins and that his blood
is shed for our forgiveness. That's what
Jesus teaches in the gospel. So then h
how can you still how do you reconcile
that because obviously the Quran is that
yeah because uh Jesus uh according to
Bible and according to Quran was sent to
B is the the children of Israel and uh
by tradition he's uh we we tell him we
we we as an Israelite himself
specifically from Judea. So he's a
Judian. So um in the in the Bible you
find that uh they are referred to as
gods always to us gods. Oh you're
talking about Psalm 82. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. So that's not what I'm worried
about brother. I'm worried I'm worried
about Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I'm coming I
mean to that Jesus being son of God.
Jesus being the son of God. You're
saying that that's reconcile that's
that's reconciled with the Quran. The
Quran teaches that Jesus is the son of
God. No. No. No. No, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no. Because um the the tradition of
it's like in America, you can call
someone you're my D. You see uh the
tradition of the Jews, they see someone
who represent God as God and also son of
God. He's a righteous man who represent
God. So that's for that that's not
Islamically, right? Because we're
talking about what Jesus talking
Islamic. Yeah. It's the tradition of the
Jews, right? So the Quran goes against
this tradition, right? It's restricting
people from taking other people's
tradition into their own tradition
because they'll confuse to say that God
has a wife and has a child as no Jew
teaches that God has a wife or anything
like that. So that's that's how Yeah.
Jews had the scriptures way before even
a thousand years before us. Yeah. But
that's not that's not dealing with the
issue here. The issue is we have what
Jesus taught. He taught that he's the
son of God, that he came to die for our
sins and rose again on the third day and
that he's going to judge the nations
when he comes back. Like he's gonna
decide who goes to heaven and hell.
Obviously, the Quran goes against all of
these teachings that Jesus taught. How
being son of God, being a son of God,
dying for our sins, all of that. Him
being the one who judges on judgment
day. I I will ask a leading question.
When do you think the judgment today
will be? Is it the return of the Jesus
Christ or Jesus will return then we'll
have later on the judgment day? Jesus
says that when he returns it's judgment
day. He's going to sit on his glorious
throne and he's going to judge the
nations. He's going to separate the
righteous from the unrighteous and he's
going to throw the unrighteous into the
lake of fire. That's what Jesus says
himself. And that will be the end of the
world. That's the end of the world. And
we going to be going. I think I read
something like he will rule for thousand
years. That's right. He'll rule for a
thousand years. New Jerusalem. New
Jerusalem and his kingdom will have no
end. He'll rule for a thousand years and
then defeat the rest of the rest of the
enemies after that thousand years and
then the new heavens and new earth
creation begins. How do you reconcile
this teaching of Jesus with the Quran?
How do you fix this problem? Because the
Quran says that this stuff is true while
at the same time contradicting it. The
stuff about the ending of the word or
for Jesus being the son of God. Jesus
being the son of just keeping it simple.
Jesus being the son of God and Jesus
coming to die for our sins and and all
that kind of stuff. The Quran goes
against that. According to my
understanding about Jesus uh uh in the
Quran Islam he was neither crucified not
nor
um nor not killed. Yeah. Exactly. It was
it was made to appear like that. Yeah.
So something happened and the people who
were present at the place they thought
that Jesus died. So I
have my teacher who taught me about
about the thing that he thinks the Quran
best explain what happened. So in uh in
in in Islam we we we term death as the
separation of uh spirit from the body.
Uhhuh. Not for just a period of time but
until the final resurrection. Okay. So,
so if someone pass out or someone when
someone sleep because the Quran is
explicitly saying that the sleeping is
one form of death. Okay. When you sleep
uh God take your soul and if the death
is written for you, he will not return
the soul to you. So that So do you
believe that Jesus did die in a in a in
a way? Don't believe that he died
because if he died uh that means u he is
still dead until now until final
resurrection. No he he rose again on the
third day and 3 days 3 days later he
rose again from the dead. Yeah, because
that's that knowledge. I don't know
about uh Christianity. How do you term
death? Is it for a given period of time?
Similarly to you, bro, but but that's
how we see death. That's that's not
relevant here. The fact that Jesus died
according to Jesus. This is what Jesus
says. He died and then Jesus also talks
about a few days later as he rose again
from the dead. This is what Jesus talks
about. So he died three days later came
back to life. So Quran is challenging
the the meaning of death. That's what
it's crucifixion. It says he was neither
killed nor did they nor crucified. Yeah.
Jesus was crucified. Jesus teaches that
he was crucified and he died. Jesus
before his death he said this generation
want a sign and they will not
get sign of Jonah. Yeah. Yeah. I I don't
mean to cut you off, bro, but you're not
uh you're not engaging with what I'm
saying. Okay. Let let me address that.
So the Quran is saying um something
happened maybe the suffering and the
that that's according to me the
suffering and the thing like that and
then the soul was separated from him and
then returned back nice
for crucifixion to be complete which is
a c by the way according to the bible
someone has to die on the cross and not
and until final the resurrection All you
got to do is be nailed to a cross, bro.
That's what a crucifixion is. You don't
have to die on that cross to in order to
be crucified. That's all. The process
the process has to be completed. Dude,
being crucified is just being nailed to
a cross beam. That's all that is. If you
die on that cross beam or not doesn't
determine or doesn't change the fact
that you were crucified. Okay? There is
there is an attempt to kill and they
kill itself. Okay? Even if you're taking
to the So, so Jesus teaches that he's
the son of God. He teaches that he was
crucified and he teaches that he rose
from the dead. Do these things conflict
with the Quran? Yeah. The Quran is quite
the opposite of the thing about
crucifixion and and killing because they
planned and Allah planned and his plan
was superseded their plan. Got it? So
we're at the point where the Quran
affirms the teachings of Jesus which we
have but at the same time the Quran
contradicts the teachings of Jesus. So
if the Quran is contradicting the
teachings of Jesus then the Quran is
false. That's your opinion. On my
opinion I see that Quran came to do the
correction necessary correction for
better understanding of what happened.
How can it do the correction if it
confirms what the previous book already
says? It says what the previous book
says is true. So it's not correcting it.
It's saying that it's true. It's backing
it up while at the same time
contradicting it. If it's contradicting
it and you are saying it is confirming
it, that means there are there is an
issue with the word confirming. We have
to know what is there's no bro. There's
an issue. What's the meaning of
confirming? There's an issue with the
Quran. It's this is what we call the
Islamic dilemma. The Quran confirms the
scripture. Hold on. The Quran says it
confirms the scripture, but then the
Quran contradicts that scripture. It
says it confirmed. That's the Islamic
dilemma. I see why you came with as a
dilemma because you are coming from the
point of that the whole Bible is a true
pure preserved word of God. I get it.
Yes. Because dude, I could be an atheist
and disregard the Bible. It has nothing
to do with the fact that the Quran
confirms the Bible and then contradicts
the Bible. So regardless if I'm a
Christian, atheist, Hindu, the Quran has
a dilemma. Period. I will come to that
word of
confirm. I I will I would like to know
more about because English is my like
third language. Confirm because from
what I I read about confirming is to
establish the the truth. Yep. To confirm
means that you establish the truth of a
thing. You attest to the truth of a
thing. means that you're whatever
whatever you're confirming you are w you
are a witness that that thing is true
and what if there are is a falsehood in
what you are confirming what will you do
if you are confirming it if I'm
confirming something that's false then
I'm false for confirm for saying that
something is true that is actually false
that's my problem yeah the confirmation
based on the truth if there is falsehood
that means the my confirmation will only
based on the truth. No, it means that
if if I could if if if you said that the
sky is pink and then I came and I said I
confirm what Abu Bakr says that the sky
I I confirm what he said but the sky is
not pink that means that you and me were
false. I'm false for confirming a false
claim that you made. That's my fault for
backing you up. You get it? Yes, I get
it. Um, so when look look the Quran is
false for if like let's say you know it
it um it it confirms the teachings of
Jesus. The teachings of Jesus say that
he's the son of God. Well, if Jesus is
not the son of God, but the Quran is
confirming the Jesus's teachings, then
the Quran is false for confirming
something that's false. If the teachings
of Jesus is false, the Quran is false
because it's confirming something that's
false. If the teachings of Jesus is
correct and he is the son of God and
since the Quran confirms it, right?
Well, the Quran is still false because
it contradicts that elsewhere. It says
Jesus is not the son of God. So, it's
going against a teaching that's true
that it claims is true. So, if the
teachings of Jesus is true, Quran is
false. If the teachings of Jesus is
false, Quran is false. Either way
because uh you you are holding the Quran
to the position that it is uh agreeing
to everything in the Bible by taking the
single word confirming while the Quran
because the the Bible said God created
heaven and earth for six days and he
rested on the seventh day. But the Quran
is correcting that by saying fatigue
never is is not something is not
something for God. So what I see what I
see what I see about confirming is not
like me confirming something. When the
scripture is confirming it is it is
establishing the truth inside that
another scripture. If there is necessary
correction then the Quran is making that
necessary correction. That's what they
understand about confirming. All right.
I appreciate it. I'm going to give
somebody else a chance. I appreciate you
uh for for trying out, Abu Bakr. I
appreciate it. Okay. All right. Take
care, man. Good night. Okay. Good night.
And that's the issue, guys. Um what Abu
Bakr did was he said, "Okay, you know
what? I see why you have the issue." And
so what I need to do is I need to we
need to re-evaluate what the word
confirm means. So we need to change how
we understand what it means to confirm
so that we can you know fix this issue
that the Quran has. So in other words,
and now this isn't, you know, literally
what Abu Bakr is saying, but this is his
position I have to assess is that in
order for you Muslims to fix this issue
of the Islamic dilemma, you have to
change what words mean. You have to
change reality. You can't stick to
definitions. You have to change them in
order to try to fix this.